[Music]
gotta catch'em all we'd love Pokemon and
today we're highlighting some of our
favorite fan art and checking out
realistic Pokemon looks can be deceiving
because the last entry shows one of the
most adorable Pokemon looking as scarier
as ever in real life if you love Pokemon
make sure you give this video a thumbs
up and subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one now let's check out
what Pokemon would look like in real
life Charmander let's start with one of
our favorite Pokemon ever Charmander is
probably one of the most recognized
characters on the show he's totally
adorable but we also love deviant arts
record biz
he did an amazing job on this one how
can a dragon with a fiery tail still
look so unbelievably cute we'd love to
keep one as a pet meow
speaking of cute characters check out
the talented Toto mames version of meow
people have mixed feelings about me out
since he belongs to Team Rocket but you
have to admit that his real-life version
would be absolutely adorable after all
how can you not love this hyper cartoon
cat with special powers make sure you
let us know which Pokemon character
you'd want to have as a pet Bulbasaur
we're still talking about cute Pokemon
although according to this concept
artist a real-life version of Bulbasaur
wouldn't be as cute joshua dunlop
created this incredibly realistic
version of everyone's favorite seed
pokemon but to be completely honest we'd
probably be just a little bit scared by
this creature what kind of noises do you
think he'd make poliwag joshua dunlop
really is a talented concept artist
because these look very real just check
out the adorable poliwag in its natural
habitat how could you ever suspect this
adorable creature could even fight in
any kind of battles yet alone when it's
the cutest thing we've ever seen and we
can't get over its swirl on its belly
squirtle don't worry we'll get to some
scary pokemon too but for now check out
another fan favorite squirtle this
illustration belongs to Joshua Dunlop
and it's hard to believe it's actually
an illustration again how is it possible
that this adorable Pokemon can be
I'm so powerful it could easily defeat
creatures just with its adorable looks
bonito bonito is a fire pokemon which is
pretty obvious considering it's pretty
much a horse with fire everywhere
check out this interesting real-life
version created by Shiva designing from
deviantART we have a feeling that grass
underneath it definitely wouldn't
survive real life ponyta stampede but
you have to admit it looks pretty
impressive Pikachu and who can forget
about the most iconic Pokemon ever
Pikachu is beloved by Minnie and Toto
MAME showed what Pikachu would
realistically look like don't forget
that it's actually just a rat so this
illustration is definitely more than
appropriate
everyone loves Pikachu but could you
handle having more than one of these
creatures around we don't think so
Charizard we already saw a real-life
Charmander but either the bulbs it can
actually get pretty scary artist RJ
Palmer beautifully showed what Charizard
would look like in its true real-life
size it's a dragon after all and this
dragon is definitely much scarier and
powerful check out these impressive
wings and at that mighty look Agron so
here's an example of a mighty pokemon
we'd all be afraid of if we saw in real
life this thing looks gigantic the
illustration belongs to RJ Palmer who
once again did an amazing job
our Grande looks pretty scary anyways
but we can imagine most people would run
as fast as they possibly can to get away
from this creature
Blastoise squirtle might be adorable but
as it evolves it becomes more and more
scarier by the minute
RJ Palmer showed what Blastoise would
look like in real life and although it
still looks kind of like a turtle it's
way too powerful just check out that
ginormous shell and the water cannons
those are the reasons to get out of
there as soon as you spot Blastoise
Machoke Machop might be cute but when it
turns into much oak it's unstoppable
leash from deviantART did an amazing job
showing what Machop would look like in
real life and to be completely honest
with you we wouldn't want to come
anywhere near this mighty beast just
look at its muscles it looks like it
could pretty much win any battle there
is bail sprouts at this plant base
Pokemon is probably one of the most
adorable characters ever FL - ZC from
deviantART did an amazing job at
reimagining this creature and real life
even though it's powerful we want to
keep it for life just look at that
adorable pout Beedrill Pokemon come in
all shapes and sizes and Delfy are from
deviantART did an amazing job at showing
Beedrill in its natural habitat it
almost looks like a regular B doesn't it
well you just have to make sure to not
make this be angry because it's known to
cause some serious damages can you spot
the Pokemon trainers in the background
Pidgey Pidgey is always present in the
beginning of every Pokemon game so most
trainers have probably come in contact
with it here's Joshua Dunlop's version
of a real life piggy and to be honest it
looks so realistic we could easily
forget this is actually a Pokemon
creature
not to mention Pidgey can be pretty
powerful overtime Nidoqueen Nidoqueen is
a half poison half grounds Pokemon and
it's definitely super powerful if you
train it well here's deviant arts Han
pure version of what this Pokemon would
look like in real life isn't it strange
how this Nidoqueen looks almost cuddly
it's definitely the Pokemon we wouldn't
want to get on our bad side though
Jigglypuff Jigglypuff is one of our
favorite Pokemon ever it's cute its
puppy and well it hits jiggly but you
might be surprised because a deviantART
artist called b4m
to see for reimagined Jigglypuff in a
much more realistic way trust us this is
anything but cute we can't imagine this
creature using the power of charm to
manipulate its enemies and that's it for
our video don't forget to subscribe to
our channel and hit the like button for
more videos like this one see you next
time
[Music]